الم فاطمه اكبر من ان يوصف وذاكرتها طبع
فيها فجر الزلزال الدامي عندما ايقظها
ارتجاف منزلها على اصوات تحطيم ما حولها
جرت فاطمه وشقيقتها الصغرى نحو ابيهما لكن
شده الزلزال تفوقت على الوقت اللازم
للهروب
فتح الباب
فاطمه منحتها الحياه فرصه اخرى مع كسر في
قدمها واختها الاصغر بيان التي اختبات في
حضن ابيها لم تصب باذى فيما اصيب الاب
بكسر في الساق لكن الانقاض ابتلعت الامه
وطفلين اخرين فيما بقيت الطفله الثالثه
ريان في عداد المفقودين ارادت
انه ليش هيك صار معنا الاب المفجوع
وابنتاه في احد مشافي ادلب البؤس ونظرات
الضياع يكسوان وجه فاطمه مع رفيق قد يطول
هو الصمت ربما لان القصه التي عاشتها تحت
الانقاض من الصعب البوح بها فالقصص تحت
الركام لا تقل قساوه عن تلك التي فوقه بل
ربما هي اشد باسا حنان المصري العربيه